[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition de
présidentielle 360 voici lé titre à lui
dit il sera t elle la prochaine victime
collatérale de la sphère fillon après le
renoncement d'alain juppé les centristes
sont orphelins un bureau exécutif doit
se tenir dans une heure alors que jean
louis borloo plaide pour une
recomposition politique qui pourrait
être portée par emmanuel macron il n'y
aura pas de rencontre entre sarkozy
fillon juppé elle est devenue caduque
après les réunions des juppéiste au
sénat et des sarkozystes à l'assemblée
nationale ce matin
objectif serré les rangs derrière le
candidat de la droite à la
présidentielle au lendemain d'un comité
politique censé clore le débat
benoît hamon contraint de revenir sur sa
mesure phare le revenu universel jugé
trop coûteux par ses détracteurs il
promet des ajustements au moment où sa
campagne patine et qu'il peine à
rassembler le décryptage
à suivre et je vous rappelle que vous
pouvez réagir en direct à cette émission
acheter avec présidentielle à 360
mais avant de développer tous ses titres
françois fillon aurait obtenu en 2013 un
près de 50000 euros de l'homme
d'affaires marc ladreit de lacharrière
un prêt sans intérêts non déclarés selon
le canard enchaîné le candidat de la
droite à la présidentielle n'a pas jugé
utile de faire figurer ses cinquante
mille euros sur sa déclaration de
patrimoine celle qu'il a adressée à la
haute autorité pour la transparence de
la vie publique c'est l'hebdo matin
l'hebdomadaire satirique qui à paraître
demain qui le révèle ce prêt a été
intégralement remboursés selon son
avocat à m antonin lévy et cette
nouvelle révélation intervient alors que
depuis hier les républicains tentent de
serrer les rangs derrière françois
fillon en l'absence de plan b ce dernier
a réussi à imposer sa candidature mais
l'unité reste fragile et difficile à
reconstruire
en témoignent ces deux rendez vous ce
matin des juppéiste au sénat et des
sarkozystes pas loin de l'assemblée
nationale a cessé siksou élevé grégoire
désemparés et esseulé les proches
d'alain juppé se sont réunis ce matin au
sénat autour de jean-pierre raffarin
après le renoncement une bonne fois pour
toutes de leur chef et le soutien du
parti à françois fillon
les juppéiste sont partagés sur leur
engagement dans la campagne
pour l'instant je vais m'occuper de mon
travail parlementaire personnes s'est
précipitée pour dire je pars tout de
suite je prends le train l'avion pour
aller faire la campagne de françois
fillon
moi j'en suis au stade de l'examen de
conscience voilà je vais me poser toutes
les bonnes questions
puisqu'il a appelé à le faire et quand
j'aurai la réponse
je vous dirai si françois fillon le
souhaite je serai à ses côtés on a eu
nombreux quelques pas en avant quelques
hésitations quelques pas en arrière
personne ne le contestera
mais encore une fois aujourd'hui la page
doit être tournée dans l'intérêt
supérieur de l'alternance est du pays au
même moment à deux pas de l'assemblée
les sarkozystes se sont donné rendez
vous dans un restaurant hier encore il
proposé à françois fillon de se choisir
un successeur
mais ce matin changement de ton tous
font désormais bloc derrière le candidat
de la droite
même les plus dubitatifs comme christian
estrosi moi je n'ai qu'une chose à dire
c'est contribuer à l'unité de toutes nos
forces avec les centristes pour éviter
une victoire de marine le pen ont fait
campagne à fond on ne fait pas campagne
et là on a décidé de faire campagne à
fond parce que le seul moyen de gagner
c'est présidentielle c'est d'être
mobilisés nous avons dit clairement
autour de la table que nous étions
engagés derrière françois fillon taylor
que celui ci a affiché sa détermination
du côté des filles nist on veut laisser
ses six semaines de psychodrame derrière
et se recentrer sur la campagne
aujourd'hui cette page et klaus et
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans la
semblement et surtout dans une campagne
et maintenant le sujet c'est pas
tellement le parti les parties etc
même s'il faut rassembler la droite et
le centre j'insiste beaucoup si sur le
mot centre mais surtout il faut aller au
contact des français
si le rassemblement semble en marche
beaucoup attendent encore le 15 mars
jour où françois fillon est convoquée
par lé et gérard larcher président du
sénat et directeur du comité politique
et dlr pour qui le débat est clos a
malgré tout annoncé ce matin pour la
première fois qu'il assume et la
distance prise est la semaine dernière
avec françois fillon assurant néanmoins
qu'il était aux côtés du candidat on les
écoute c'était ce matin sur france inter
moi je lui ai dit directement dans son
bureau n'étions que tous les deux parce
que je considérais à cette époque qu'il
était impossible de conduire la campagne
or en démocratie conduire une campagne
c'est le projet le pacte à faire avec
les français
bon aujourd'hui ils vous lui avez dit
cette candidature monsieur puisque je
lui avais dit qu'il me semblait opportun
de cesser cette candidature
aujourd'hui si vous a fait changer
d'avis c'est parce qu'il m'a fait
changer d'avis c'est qu'aujourd'hui il
n'ya pas d'autre alternative que
françois fillon
il doit porter le projet le débat était
clos c'est moi même qui l'a annoncé
j'assume je suis l'impôt et 116 5
millions et je suis aux côtés de
françois fillon pour faire partager aux
français le projet qui est le meilleur
le seul qui peut redresser la france et
dans cette campagne pour la
présidentielle ils ont obtenu les 500
parrainages nécessaires pour être
officiellement candidat emmanuel macron
benoît hamon nicolas dupont aignan et
nathalie arthaud à noter qu'alain juppé
a également reçu 240 de parrainage
beaucoup misé d'ailleurs sur lui alain
juppé mais après le renoncement du maire
de bordeaux la famille centriste se sent
orpheline ceux qui rejettent françois
fillon ne savent plus qui soutenir dans
cette campagne du bout des lèvres jean
louis borloo cofondateur de l'udi tend
la main à emmanuel macron une réunion au
sénat s'est terminée il ya quelques
instants
je vous propose d'écouter les réactions
à la sortie au micro de jean marie notre
groupe n'est pas un adepte de la de la
position commune est donc l'objectif de
cette réunion n'était certainement pas
de se prononcer en faveur de tel ou tel
candidat
vous savez moi
il ya une époque où j'étais le seul
parmi tous les membres du groupe à
soutenir françois fillon donc la
situation n'est certainement pas pire
qu'à ce moment là
merci la confiance est ébranlée et la
question pourquoi fillon aujourd'hui
s'ils souhaitent un accord avec
centriste c'est clairement de se
positionner en partenaire qui prend en
compte votre point de vue et il ne peut
pas y avoir pour lui ni dairy populiste
ni dérive sur un thème qui serait sous
la droite identitaire nous nous avons
apporté notre témoignage des raisons qui
nous ont fait soutenir monsieur macron
et vous avez bon espoir que d'autres
vous rejoignent sur cette position ça
c'est peut-être exprimer vous savez moi
j'ai toujours eu un horaire c'est que la
famille centriste soit réuni et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les conditions politiques
le sont pour recréer en france un centre
fort donc j'espère oui que beaucoup nous
rejoindront ce n'est pas encore une
désaffection et les atermoiements de
claude bartolone le président de
l'assemblée nationale qui dit ne pas se
reconnaître dans la campagne de benoît
hamon reflète l'état d'esprit de
nombreux parlementaires à gauche
certains s'interrogent sur leur soutien
franc et massif aux candidats issus de
la primaire sans toutefois franchir le
pas et rejoindre le leader dans marche
conséquence la campagne de benoît hamon
peine à décoller sandra cerqueira benoît
hamon peine à faire entendre sa voix sa
campagne patine la défiance d'une partie
de son camp y est pour beaucoup
une situation qu'il tente de minimiser à
tout prix ah si je devais m'inquiéter
être en colère bon pour ça je dois moi
tout va bien tu envahissante et benoît
hamon tenterait de rassurer il envisage
de revoir sa copie sur le revenu
universel objectif le rendre moins
coûteux et faire un geste pour les plus
bas salaires
c'était une demande des valses east et
des hollandais mais son entourage la
sueur pas question de revenir sur le
principe même du revenu unis
il ya eu d'emblée de la part de benoît
hamon certaine clarté en disant mais
c'est pas une mesure qui est prête à
l'emploi si je puis dire
il y aura nécessairement un temps de
concertation important c'est pas quelque
chose qu'on peut mettre en place du jour
au lendemain pour les réformateurs du ps
tenté par emmanuel macron la fracture
idéologique au sein du parti est telle
que ce geste de benoît hamon ne suffira
pas à le rendre crédible et je ne crois
pas que la tentative de benoît hamon
d'arnaud montebourg baisse bref des
frondeurs depuis 2012 de se séparer du
ps gouvernementale jusqu'à renier le
bilan et et de dire qu'on sera plus pur
et c'est comme ça qu'on confondait ma
basse et de pinèdes c'est une
c'est une grande idée des années 80
quand on avait un parti communiste à 25%
c'est une idée qui conduit à installer
la droite au pouvoir garder son
électorat de la primaire sans se fâcher
avec sa famille politique
benoît hamon continue de marcher sur un
fil d'équilibriste
et pour parler de cette campagne mais
invité sur ce plateau et la kribi
romdhane bonjour vous êtes conseil
régional ps d'île de france 2 porte
parole de benoît hamon merci d'être avec
nous christophe caresche est également
présent bonsoir vous êtes député ps de
paris
vous venez de soutenir officiellement
emmanuel macron vous étiez d'ailleurs un
des co signataires d'une tribune parue
fin janvier dans le monde invoquant un
droit de retrait de la campagne
justement du vainqueur de cette primaire
benoît hamon
première question pour vous et la kribi
romdhane que pouvez vous dire à claude
bartolone qui ce soir dans un entretien
au monde dit ne pas se reconnaître dans
la campagne menée par benoît hamon je
suis très étonné des propos de claude
bartolone que je connais bien puisque
j'ai eu l'occasion de faire une campagne
avec lui une campagne où il a eu des
propositions de gauche où il a été
entouré de candidats issus de la gauche
j'en faisais partie
puisque j'étais sur une liste sur la
liste d'île de france
et puis où il a eu aussi besoin de la
gauche et de la gauche du parti
socialiste pour procéder au
rassemblement au deuxième tour et donc
moi je m'étonne de voir que claude
bartolone tient de tels propos
il parle d'une version de mon notamment
sur la question de la fin du travail et
donc de la mise en place du revenu
universel dont mais les bagages de
claude bartolone enfin je ne sais pas à
la question du travail moi je pense que
claude bartolone est probablement un peu
fatigué il est député depuis 1981 il ne
se représente pas aux élections
législatives en faisant ce choix elle ne
prend pas de grands risques en tenant
ces propos et que donc voilà benoît
hamon il ne compte pas sur les ceux qui
ont certes probable mais ça termine ce
manque de soutien
je ne le pense pas parce qu'il est
tourné vers les français il n'a pas
gagné la primaire avec le soutien des
mammouths du parti socialiste mais avec
le soutien des français de la gauche du
peuple de gauche en france et c'est ce
qui continue à faire dans cette campagne
c'est pas une campagne qui patine c'est
une campagne où il est sur le terrain où
il s'adresse avant tout à ses électeurs
christophe caresche c'est ce que les
propos de claude bartelone reflet d'un
peu l'état d'esprit je le dise
de nombreux parlementaires aujourd'hui
d'abord claude bartolone n'est pas un
mammouth
c'est un homme qui depuis le début de sa
vie politique a inscrit celle ci dans le
parti socialiste il est président de
l'assemblée nationale il a été ministre
il a eu des responsabilités importantes
il a été notre candidat effectivement
aux élections régionales je pense qu'il
faut écouter ce qu'il dit il faut le
prendre au sérieux
il ya incontestablement un malaise dont
je suis peut-être un des indicateurs
mais honnêtement je ne suis pas le seul
pourquoi d'abord parce que dans la
campagne des primaires c'est vrai que
benoît hamon a développé un programme
une orientation qui est pour beaucoup
très opposé à ce qu'on a défendu durant
le quinquennat et puis sur un certain
nombre d'orientations notamment le
revenu universel il ya l'autre point
c'est que benoît hamon a perdu beaucoup
de temps c'est à dire que il s'est
immédiatement tourné vers monsieur jadot
et monsieur mélenchon ça a duré quand
même quelques semaines et je pense que
effectivement ce malaise s'est installé
parce qu'il a peut-être un peu oublié de
parler à ses amis et aux députés
notamment aux parlementaires mais
au-delà de cela il y a quand même soyons
clairs des divergences de fond qui sont
qui sont pas nouvelles et qui
apparaissent à l'occasion de cette
campagne et qui va amener
inéluctablement un certain nombre de
socialistes à faire des choix différents
que celle du soutien à leur candidat
soyons clairs c'est pourquoi je sens
bien sûr un peu de pied sur la question
du revenu universel et je me juge je
veux juste dire qu'on choisit pas tel ou
tel candidat parce qu'il a perdu du
temps parce qu'il a gagné du temps on
choisit un candidat parce qu'il a été
plébiscité 20 je veux dire quand claude
bartolone ou d'autres ont été élus grâce
au parti socialiste pendant des
décennies la moindre des choses c'est de
respecter et les statuts du parti
socialiste et le verdict des urnes qui
affecte deux millions plus de deux
millions d'électeurs de gauche se sont
déplacés pour choisir leur candidat à
l'élection présidentielle et il se
trouve que benoît hamon a été plébiscité
puisqu'il obtient près de 60% des voix à
la prix
donc tout ça n'est pas à géométrie
jugement des réformateurs des
sélectionnés bien je me sens pas
forcément représentés dans cette forme
dans les bases parce que ça fait très
longtemps qu'on en vous faites pour
justement les réintégrer en fait chez
les mots a dit je pense que ce jeu
d'abord s'il n'ya pas d'hémorragie
je vous invite à regarder le nombre de
députés qui rejoint aimé des électeurs
ça c'est ce qu'on verra dans les yeux
tout à fait je vous invite à avoir le
nombre de députés conjoint emmanuel
macron mais juste de dire que tout ça
n'est qu'un prétexte à fait des années
qu'on entend les réformateurs dire
qu'ils rêvent d'un parti avec le centre
alors il se trouve qu'aujourd'hui ils
font le choix d'un candidat qui est
celui du centre droit qui est
caractérisée comme tel avec 7 des
propositions qui sont proches de celles
de françois fillon s'est même des
propositions qui sont saluées pour
certaines d'entre elles par laurence
parisot qui dit elle même que la vision
de deux des manuels macron est très
proche de celle de françois fillon bon
voilà on a aujourd'hui une candidate
d'extrême droite un candidat de la
droite dure et qui restent candidats un
candidat de centre droit qu'emmanuel
macro et puis un candidat a mené à
rassembler la gamme annonce un candidat
de centre droit vous d'accord avec cette
étiquette
non je pense que c'est tout autre chose
dans ce qui est vrai c'est que danse
dans ces circonstances mais que je
regrette
honnêtement durant ces cinq dernières
années
s'il avait fallu que les députés
socialistes respecte les statuts du
parti socialiste la discipline du groupe
j'aurais été le premier à m'ont félicité
ce n'est pas ce que j'ai constaté
donc à partir de ce moment il faut pas
s'étonner non plus que lorsqu'on a eu un
comportement
j'allais dire on appelait ça frondeurs
pendant des années et bien évidemment
c'est difficile après de demander au nom
de cette unité au nom de cette
discipline aux autres de ceux de se
rassembler mais le sujet n'est pas c'est
pas le sujet est plus profond que cela
d'un certain point de vue je pourrais
dire presque
malheureusement la vérité c'est que on
en revient ses deux gosses il ya une
radicalisation il y à une radicalisation
même si j'aime pas trop ce terme disons
que benoît hamon et ils l'assument
je ne lui reproche pas je ne porte pas
de jugement de valeur sur benoît hamon
en plus c'est quelqu'un que j'aime bien
qui est sympathique a été admis
collègues que je connais depuis très
longtemps donc ce n'est pas benoît hamon
qui est en cause il a un choix
stratégique et il a un choix
g qui n'est pas dans lequel un certain
nombre de socialistes ne se
reconnaissent pas et ça il faut le
comprendre
et de ce point de vue là je suis
d'accord la primaire est-ce qu'elle a
véritablement tranché des choses je n'en
suis pas certain parce que la vérité
c'est que là la primaire elle s'est
déroulé avec des projets extrêmement
antagonistes extrêmement contradictoires
qu'on le veuille ou non est donc la
primaire ça plus été à mon avis le le
constat de nos désaccords que la
possibilité les conditions de se
rassembler il aurait fallu d'ailleurs
benoît hamon le comprennent tout de
suite il n'a pas voulu pour ça lui
appartient encore une fois je ne cherche
pas à le halal caricaturé mais il n'a
pas voulu faire ce travail et donc c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui le doute s'est
installé
pas seulement chez les réformateurs ou
si chez ce parce qu'évidemment pour ses
camarades la droite el commandante
comment comment on peut justement d'en
bouffer redevenir justement ceux chez
qui le doute s'est installé
peut-être cette question du revenu
universel on sait qu'il va mais proposer
une nouvelle mouture il veut rassurer
montrer que finalement cette mesure qui
avait fait l'unanimité contre elle
pendant la primaire à gauche bien ça ne
va pas ruiner l'état c'est ce qu'il dit
aujourd'hui benoît hamon d'abord moi je
veux vraiment définitivement dire que
veut nous avons fait le choix et que
l'on doit saluer de tourner le dos à la
vieille politique et à la petite
tambouille politicienne qui consiste à
dire donne moi le sel le poivre et
benoît hamon il se tourne vers les
français
le rassemblement il l'a fait il l'a fait
avec les écologistes il parle au peuple
de gauche et même dans sa famille que la
famille socialiste à qui les aurait
orientés ambition avouée à saisir
justement puisque nous vous le savez il
ya sessler une certaine démarche de
françois hollande qui sont aujourd'hui
porte parole de benoît hamon il ya des
proches de manuel valls qui est des
porte-parole de manuel valls pendant la
primaire qui sont aujourd'hui dans
l'équipe de campagne de benoît hamon il
y en a plusieurs dizaines de ses
responsables politiques qui n'avaient
pas fait le choix de benoît remet et qui
respecte le verdict des urnes dans la
vie c'est comme ça il ya les mauvais
perdants
malheureusement il n'accepte pas ce
choix du peuple de gauche et puis il ya
ceux qui jouent le jeu et qui disent nos
électeurs ont tranché comme on l'a fait
en 2012 avec françois hollande
je faisais partie et benoît hamon aussi
de ceux qui n'avaient pas choisi
françois hollande mais qui ont fait
pleinement campagne tous les jours pour
françois hollande pour qu'il soit élu
président de la république
c'est ce que nous nourrissons nourris
perdants se désole que les proches de
benoît hamon voit les choses comme ça
parce que je pense qu'ils ne comprennent
pas que le malaise est beaucoup plus
profond en 2012 des choses était très
différente parce qu'en réalité il y
avait un projet du parti socialiste et
chaque candidat avait eu à coeur
d'essayer de respecter ce projet donc
nous n'étions pas dans des offres
politiques aussi antagonistes bon donc à
partir de là j'allais dire que on est
dans un processus malheureusement un peu
attendu qui est celui d'une division
profonde du parti socialiste et
d'ailleurs je pense que le parti
socialiste aurait intérêt à entériner
une fois pour toutes cette division et a
laissé un certain nombre de ceux qui
veulent soutenir les manuels macron le
faire et ceux qui veulent évidemment
soutient benoît hamon le faire parce que
je ne crois pas aujourd'hui que ce soit
par des des processus disciplinaire ou
et c'est qu'on va régler les problèmes
donc voila et je pars ce que je constate
que cette ce désaccord il s'est encore
exprimé aujourd'hui au groupe
je le dis clairement à l'assemblée
nationale ce désaccord est assez tête à
ces irréductibles il faut dire
clairement les accords pas bon et
pourtant c'est ce qu'on prend de changer
de système réunion avec plusieurs
dizaines
une centaine de députés socialistes il
ya une semaine c'était passe pas
exactement ce que j'ai ressenti
moi je veux le dire benoît hamon il fait
le choix de s'adresser aux français
aujourd'hui à marseille pour parler du
vieillissement et de nos aînés qui
vieillissent mal et dans de mauvaises
conditions
hier il était à bastia au contact de
gestion de versements passionnel soutien
de quoi on parlait de claude barth et
les candidats qu'ils font choix de faire
de favoriser l'autre soit et la
tambouille politicienne et à ceux qui
veulent s'adresser aux français et
rassembler avant tout les français parce
qu'on est face à de grands défis de
société et on a aussi une population qui
vit de grandes difficultés
c'est à eux qu'il faut parler dans un
contexte où l affaire fillon et d'autres
hélas faire le pen crée déjà un climat
suffisamment tendue et nauséabond pour
qu'on ait en rajouter davantage avec
ares jeunes on sait que claude bartolone
me lis pas franchement mais il hésite
encore à soutenir benoît hamon ou
peut-être rejoindre emmanuel macron ce
n'est pas le seul est ce que vous pensez
que d'autres personnalités politiques
pourraient justement bien deux choses
qui sont qui sont qui sont rejoindre les
leaders de la première c'est qu'il ya un
certain nombre de responsables
socialistes qui aujourd'hui estime que
ces thèmes une aile emmanuel macron qui
peut au deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle parce que c'est sale
quand même le sujet faire barrage au
front national et je pense que ça peut
les amener qui ça peut les amener
effectivement à soutenir un manuel
macron pour cette raison là
le deuxième point c'est quel manuel
macro soyons clairs ouvre une
perspective que je trouve
personnellement intéressante c'est à
dire d'établir non pas une force
centriste mais une force centrale
européenne réformiste avec effectivement
des responsables politiques qui viennent
de différents horizons pour essayer de
mettre en place des solutions pour
sortir effectivement la france de la
crise
mais d'avoir une majorité qui soit
cohérente merci christophe caresche
merci beaucoup et la crise d'abord été
mes invités la transition est toute
faite avec michel grossiord qui nous
rejoint tout de suite sur ce plateau
d'on soir michel puisque l'invité de
l'épreuve de vérité ce soir c'est le
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
jean christophe cambadélis vous lui
poserez justement cette question sur
bien les soutiens qui eut à venir des
parlementaires socialistes à emmanuel
mac bien sûr ce sera l'une des
thématiques de l'émission ce soir est ce
que jean christophe cambadélis et le
parti socialiste pour encore résisté
longtemps à la tentation macron nous lui
demanderons également pourquoi la
campagne de benoît hamon patiner oui à
14 % voire moins dans les intentions de
vote aujourd'hui 16% selon un autre
institut et ses tondeuses institut alors
il y en a deux autres qui le met à 13 me
et puis nous interrogerons également
jean christophe cambadélis sur la
situation politique à droite sur le
psychodrame fillon est ce que c'est une
aubaine pour la gauche ou est ce que
c'est un chaos qui risque d'emporter
tous et qui en portent déjà la campagne
présidentielle il s'agit de désigner
faut-il le rappeler le prochain chef de
l'état de la france
merci beaucoup michel l'épreuve de
vérité c'est donc à suivre en direct dès
8h30 en attendant je vous propose de
revenir sur l'audition mais rennes désir
il a été entendu aujourd'hui par les
sénateurs à deux jours du sommet
européen le secrétaire d'état aux
affaires européennes a livré son point
de vue les meilleurs extraits
sélectionnés par les formes que ça le
premier sujet qui sera à l'ordre du jour
ce sera donc celui des questions liées à
la croissance à l'emploi à la
compétitivité et le conseil débattra en
présence du président de la banque
centrale européenne mario draghi
livrera ses analyses la situation
économique aujourd'hui dans les états
membres est marquée par la reprise de la
croissance la croissance qui est
encourageante
aussi bien dans la zone euro que pour
l'europe dans son ensemble le chômage
reste cependant trop élevé même s'il
connaît une décrue significative
atteignant son niveau le plus bas depuis
2009 l'investissement progresse dans
toute l'europe mais il doit encore être
soutenu dans la durée et dans certains
états membres
il retrouve tout juste le niveau d'avant
la crise de 2008 est certain nombre
d'états membres n'ont toujours pas
retrouvé le niveau de pib qu'ils avaient
avant cette crise tous les états membres
ont fait des efforts de réduction des
déficits l'assainissement de leurs
finances publiques a été engagé il faut
donc consolider cette dynamique générale
qui est en cours mais en ayant présent à
l'esprit le contexte d'incertitudes
internationales et les fragilités qu'il
peut représenter et donc tout doit être
fait pour renforcer la reprise et
assurer sa durabilité
pour ce qui concerne l'union européenne
cela signifie évidemment que le conseil
européen encouragera la poursuite des
réformes de la modernisation de nos
économies du soutien à l'investissement
notamment en utilisant le plan juncker
dont il est prévu vous le savez qu'ils
soient étendues quasiment doublé dans sa
capacité de soutien aux investissements
pour passer de 315 à 500 milliards
d'euros de soutien au secteur clé de
notre économie en particulier le
numérique la transition énergétique les
transports le développement durable le
renforcement du marché unique sera
également débattue en particulier là
encore dans le domaine du numérique et
de l'énergie numérique parce que c'est
un domaine dans lequel il y a encore
beaucoup de de bénéfices à attendre en
termes d'innovation si l'on peut abattre
un certain nombre de cloisonnement de
barrières entre les états membres
mais il y a des problèmes de régulation
il ya par exemple pour la france des
questions qui tiennent aux droits
d'auteur au financement de la création
et c'est toutes ces questions sur
lesquelles il faut travailler pour
lesquels il faut accélérer les décisions
concernant
l'analyse par la commission de la
situation économique française je
réponds la question du président jean
bizet et du président bouvard l'analyse
de la commission et qu' elle confirme
que le déficit français sera bien en
dessous de la barre des 3 2 3 % en 2017
avec une estimation à 2,9 pour cent ce
qui serait une première depuis 2007 la
commission dresse un tableau positif de
la situation française avec une
croissance bien orienté elle était de
1,2 pour cent en 2016
les prévisions de la commission sont 1,4
pour cent pour cette année 2010 7 7% en
2018 elle estime que le chômage devrait
baisser grâce en particulier au pacte de
responsabilité au crédit d'impôt pour la
compétitivité et l'emploi et au plan
d'urgence pour l'emploi qui a été
adoptée l'année dernière et elle prévoit
également une amélioration des
exportations il n'ya pas donc de
révision qui soit prévu pour ce qui
concerne les éléments que la france
gouvernement français a inscrit dans la
loi de finances
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette édition tout de
suite l'épreuve de vérité qui reçoit ce
soir jean-christophe cambadélis le
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
bonne soirée à tous et à demain 18h
[Musique]
vous rendez vous avec public sénat
présidentielle 2017 quel rôle et quels
moyens pour les départements et la
décentralisation
l'assemblée des départements de france
interroge les candidats à l'elysée un
événement à suivre en direct sur les
chaînes parlementaires
demain à 9 heures
[Musique]
public sénat au coeur du débat